he's a professional football player who
plays for Real Madrid and the Portuguese
national team he's the first player to
win four European Golden Shoe awards he
became the world's most expensive player
when I moved from Manchester United to
Real Madrid in 2009
he's Cristiano Ronaldo and here are his
top 10 rules for success
everyone in my family love football
well I remember I always split a plane
in the street one day my father coming
and he said to me why you don't coming
for the club when I when I work I say
yes why not
and I start to play you know to have the
same routine and I start I go to every
day to training and I like it to be part
of you know a team and I training every
day and you know my father was there to
help me well in the beginning I feel
that I have I was different than the
other kids
yes I feel but I didn't even thinking
that one day will be professional and
playing for example in manchester united
around jadam even in sporting I just
play you know to enjoy but I'm never
thinking that's a have talents and I'm
gonna be professional in the beginning I
didn't feel that way from the beginning
shoots
a second gone
beautiful here
videos a Tucker
this is very important for me I'm always
competitive player and not just in the
games I'm maturing I'm like that in a
home with my sisters in my mom with my
nephews I'm always try to competitive
hard and try to win unlike that no I'm
not I'm not I never change and because I
like I like this I like what I do I like
my life I'm happy person so computing is
part of my life so in Madeira and Madrid
in England I wasn't doing all this
competitive person so it's part of me
to be
it's not existent with a Spanish Mahalo
for Christians
why make the move from manchester
united's aroma droid when he did I think
everything of a beginning and hand and
everything so what I I do what I did in
Manchester is completely finished
because I win almost everything there so
I always try for a new challenge this is
why I try to do to move Manchester for
Madrid not about the the contract is
about new challenge my family too close
to my family
different whether the language
everything and most the most important
things what I move is a challenge
because I really like to put myself in a
pressure to see what I can can can do
the first thing and the most important
thing for me it's it's football of
course nothing above that well of course
this kind of stuff I like it too
something that I thought I was involved
many many years since I was 18 so it's
something that I like it but of course
my my first focuses of course the photo
but the fashion is something that I like
it too
to tell you
the people really don't know you who is
the people to judge something that they
don't know of course this is it's
something that I don't like but I have
to leave you that I cannot change cannot
change my personality can cannot change
my character I cannot change my
education you know I respect the people
but of course I don't agree because the
real people who know me in also is
Christian oh you understand so I cannot
change the mind of the other people
maybe sometimes in the pitch I show
something that the people don't don't
want or don't like but this is my my
kind of way to to thinking because I'm
ambition person and I don't smile a lot
in the pitch because I I try to be
focused but in this in one point I will
understand some people because you know
in a life well always the people who
judge us but I think sometimes this is
not fair but you know we have to live
with that
the genius of this bad water hit
David change stood like a statue you
have to work I tried to do it almost
every day
this is why I'm in the top level many
many years I think it's not it's not by
confidence it's a because I do it extra
outside the pitch when I'm 12 years old
most of the people told me Christian we
are very very good talent player but you
are very skinny very slim and I put it
in my mind the body we can improve we
can improve you got gym duplication and
not work you can improve so I will
improve myself athleticism means a lot
for me I think the small details in hand
gonna make a huge difference to compare
with with the other players so I think
it's very important to do this kind of
work and I think it's going well on me
this is why I'm in good shape
almost all the year and I want to carry
on like that because it's helped me a
lot it's part of me I'm not doing that
kind of work because I have to it's
because it's part of me
from Cristiano Ronaldo qulity Ronaldo
largest the Riyadh
to question a mini case yes I assume
your since 1970 c0 man saw cinnamon's
Arkansas bravissimo semi are 17 seconds
so professional cameraman solo pensar
que unos presenting denied nine times M
asam you think Pensarn a mini
proficiency or pause no ser más naming a
cabeza
we do the talking
records matter to you nothing zero I
just try to do my best every season to
win the the Golden Boot it's it's
important for me is my second one and
it's something that I look forward for
that I ever put in you now to to say
thank you to my teammates because they
they helped me a lot they give me great
passes to score goals but is you know
what I say a few interviews before I
will change the on personal things for
collective Wars like champions or La
Liga because it's the most important but
in terms of individual I think I are
playing very very good this season and
really really up with what I did
it's not existing with the Spanish
and follow his dreams work hard many
many important people and people who are
expect a lot especially my my dad in my
mom always give me you should you should
respect if you want respect you should
respect the other people and this is
what always putting in my mind if you
see my my career at the last six seven
years I am always a kind of similar
level why as I said before is a long
process is the dedication it's hard work
and for the future I will try to
maintain the same I'm gonna I'm gonna
push myself until my body and give me
good answer so this is why I'm enjoy the
present and I don't think a lot about
the future because I know the future
will be good too but I just enjoyed the
moments I feel good my body's good maybe
the best moments of my career so far and
I want to continue
it
Oh
was a move
you
you're on pocket pocket Tama look
yeah hey good what I meant
Chara's are Islamorada telephone
I'm gonna play what
wait look i'm Sansui
yah-ha look
whoa
Oh punish the caretta caretta yeah
what
watch that okay so as I said really see
what Hama Hama have you move you
you go
with the demos
yeah
my
the genius of this man watch a hit David
James stood like a statue thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Marlo Acosta asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of Cristiano
Ronaldo's top ten rules meant the most
to you leave it in the comments and I'll
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon